[Music]
and that breaking news we are tracking
from the las vegas raiders this evening
mike mayock is out as general manager
good evening to you thank you for
joining us on eight news now at five i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez so we
have team coverage on big changes for
the silver and black let's get right
over to sports director chris matthews
with this giant move tonight chris all
right now two days after the raiders
were bounced from the playoffs the team
making a huge move today after three
years raiders have fired general manager
mike mayok the organization making the
announcement this afternoon here is
their statement we have relieved mike
mayok of his duties as general manager
of the las vegas raiders we thank mike
for his contributions over the last
three years in helping to form the
foundation for the franchise to build
upon its future mayok was hand-picked by
john gruden during his tenure as general
manager his team was one game above 500
25 wins 24 losses as gm he was in charge
of personnel and assessing player talent
here are the first round players picked
by mayak and gruden over the last three
years cleland farrell josh jacobs
jonathan abram damon arnett henry ruggs
and alex leatherwood certainly by high
first round standards most of them would
be considered at best at this point
misses that certainly could change
though to his credit he did hit on a few
late round guys like max crosby hunter
renfro trayvon merrick nate hobbs and
devine diablo mayok was helpful in
bringing in free agents yannick gakway
and denzel perryman he was also hired to
replace reggie mckenzie just four years
ago now with more on the head coach rich
versace and who knows his status even
he's not sure tonight here's kevin
martin yeah chris it's going to be one
busy off season for the raiders that's
for sure and first things first is
naming a long-term head coach after
saturday's season ending loss derek carr
and max crosby and a number of other
players heavily endorsed the current
interim head coach rich vesaccia vegas
went 7-5 under versace to finish the
season 10-7 and earned the franchise's
first playoff birth since 2016. and
while besancia said he has spoken with
owner mark davis about the position he
understands there's a prof process and
davis will be interviewing other
candidates
regardless he said it felt good to have
backing from his players
you know that what a great gesture right
i'm not going to stand here and say no i
don't think that's great and i don't
appreciate that and
it was it was never asked for actually
there was
there were meetings that we had where i
i almost you know
kind of explicitly told them
don't do that or you don't have to do
that or that's not why we're all here
and uh so for them to do that um i'm
very thankful and grateful for that so
after helping guide the raiders to just
their second playoff birth since 2002
there's an argument to be made that he
has earned the right to be the team's
head coach for at least another season
so all eyes will be on the raiders in
the coming weeks to see if they do
indeed go in that direction or start
fresh and bring in someone new as davis
has an important call to make when it
comes to the direction of this franchise
for not only 2022 but beyond